and that's not unit twisting forget what
you heard Travis Scott and Kylie Jenner
are doing a-okay amid rumors of tension
between the wrapper and the Keeping Up
with the Kardashians star
Travis continues to publicly support his
leading lady on Tuesday night the 21
year old Kylie cosmetics founder took to
Instagram to share this pic of herself
rocking a sheer long-sleeved shirt dress
that not so subtly showed off her
colorful lingerie baby okay after seeing
the sexy shot on social media Travis who
is currently on his Astro World Tour
commented with heart eye emojis the
flirty social media exchange comes one
month after Travis slammed a report
claiming he cheated on Kylie I don't
know it's just not cool now a source
tells e.t quote Travis and Kylie are
doing really well although they've had
their recent issues they've moved past
that and are moving forward the source
adds Travis and Kylie are a young couple
first-time parents and this is all new
to them they are taking each day as an
opportunity to grow and learn as a
couple Travis's tour is almost over and
the couple is looking forward to
spending quality time together when
rumors first started swirling that
Travis had cheated on Kylie he
immediately postponed his February 28th
concert in Buffalo New York a show that
was set to start just hours later
according to a report
Travis pulled out of the concert to be
in LA with Kylie at the time his rep
told e.t quote Travis Scott vehemently
denies he cheated on Kylie it is not
true he did not cheat adding he canceled
one show tonight because he is under the
weather the 27 year old then deleted his
Instagram page only to reactivate it
hours later